تشابه في منتصف بتكون العشرينات راح تلاقي
زي كتاب رح تدخل خلاله بقصص ما حنحكي اكثر
عنه بس ولكن عالم الاساطير راح نشوف راح
نشوفها بتنوع حتى
تلعبهم والشخصيات راح تلعبهم متنوعه يعني
احنا المشاهدين صرنا ب 15 رمضان هلا حنبلش
مسلسل
ات مع شاهد ستشاهد كل ما هو جديد
طيب اليوم عندك كمان مسلسل تحت الوصايا
تحت الوصايا اللي كانت ترند من قبل ما
يطلع يعني من قبل ما يبتدي رمضان والكل
كان عم بيحكي عن منى زكي وشو الدور اللي
عم بتقدمه طبعا احنا هون عم نشوف منى زكي
اللي مسؤوله عن اولادها بعد وفاه زوجها
كيف راح تقدر تصارع بهاي الحياه طبعا
حياتها حتكون صعبه كامراه نشوفها كصياده
صياده اسماك كمان هذا الموضوع ممكن يكون
جديد وغريب عليها شو الصراعات والاشياء
اللي راح تشوفها هي بالمسلسل طبعا احنا
راح نعيشها معاها طيب مسلسل اللي بعده
تغيير جوله مننا شلبي كمان 15 حلقه راح
ينطلق تصويره طبعا كان بين مصر ولبنان عم
نشوف احنا
كيف راح تتغير حياه منا شلبي يعني المسلسل
بعد ما عم بتروح على لبنان بحيث انها بدها
تقابل قرايبها وتشوف انه
موضوع العقار تبعها شو صار فيه انا عم
بحاول صراحه انا عم بعرف القصص عم بحاول
الاحداث بس انا صراحه مستمتع او متحمس لل
15 حلقات جايين القادمين من المسلسلات
ثلاثه لانه الثلاث مسلسلات عم بيحكوا عن
قوه المراه وكيف قدروا الثلاثه انهم
يعيشوا بحياه ويسارعوا بهاي الحياه طيب
يوسف شو بنقدر نحكي كمان عن مسلسل الصندوق
هيك رؤوس اقلام كمان صندوق هو عالم
الاثاره والتشويق صندوق بوصل بعيد ميلاد
لاحد الاشخاص بيكون بيعطي رسائل فبصيروا
ابطال العمل بدهم يلحقوا هذه الرسائل بحس
انهم يحلوا
جرائم
فلكل بحب عالم الجريمه عالم الاثاره
والتشويق فالصندوق هو اختيارهم
يعني شو كيف شفتوا التفاعل الجمهور مع
فكره ال15 حلقه في الدراميه شوفي فكره 15
حلقه يعني احنا كنا سبحان الله عم نحكي
عنها اليوم الصبح انه فكره انك انت برمضان
هذا صار عنا عددها اكثر السنه الماضيه
مسلسل واحد هلا احنا عم نحكي عن قريب الست
مسلسلات موجوده بال 15 حلقه ورمضان الجاي
ممكن يكون اكثر ففكره انه الحلقات القصيره
المشاهد صار ارتبط فيها اكثر والقصه بتكون
اسرع ما فيها بيكون مط اكثر بتكوني انت
مرتبطه بالاحداث اكثر ففكره عنصر حلقه
بالعكس شيء جميل والمنصات طبعا بدات فيه
والتلفزيونات هلا ماشيين عليه واحنا اكيد
نشكرك جزيل الشكر يوسف زين الدين المتحدث
في منصه شاهد كنت معنا هنا في الاستوديو
شكرا